Speaker 1: I did a stream last night
as news breached the wires of Donald
Trump's federal indictment, and one of
the individuals who we watched live have
a complete and total mental breakdown on live
television was this Fox News host Mark Levin,
who some consider to be a great legal analyst.
I have not seen a meltdown like this in years
on media of any kind. You've got to see this.
Here is Mark Levin essentially saying this is
nonsense. Trump is innocent. They're going after
him for politics. This guy should maybe try decaf.
Speaker 3: And list meetings, endless
meetings with with Biden, served with Hunter
Biden's business partners, Bobulinski, who
ties Joe Biden to the crimes. Mr. Big. Mr.
10%. And what does Biden say? Well, then
where's the money? He's asking us? Come
and catch me if you can. The idea that this
man is an under criminal investigation and
that they criminalize that damn document case to
go after Donald Trump is sickening. And I would
say this to our fellow Americans.
Speaker 1: This was, by the way,
during the HANNITY program. HANNITY Just
standing by during this entire thing.
Speaker 3: Don't be bamboozled by these cable
channels and these fools who come on and tell you.
Speaker 1: Like this guy.
Speaker 3: He's not above the law. Are
you kidding me? Democrat attorney general in New
York, Democrat prosecutor in Manhattan, Democrat
prosecutor in Atlanta, Democrat Attorney general
in Washington, DC. What do you mean? He's not
above the law? There is no law. What's going on
here is a disgusting disgrace. It is war on Trump.
Speaker 1: Isn't this the best?
Speaker 3: It is war on the Republican
Party and it is a war on a republic. The
radical left is doing what the radical left
does while they cover up for Biden the
way they cover it up, Hillary cover up.
Speaker 1: Whites bring evidence of crimes. They
seem furious that other presidents or presidential
candidates aren't also getting indicted just
because it looks like Trump committed crimes.
Here is this went on. There were viewers who
were tuning out and then tuning back into the
stream. And Levin was still going.
Speaker 3: Tell you something,
There are tens of millions of us. You have
crossed the Rubicon twice what has never been
done, and we will never forgive you. Never,
ever. And that's the bottom line. I'm done.
Speaker 1: All right. And so he was done. But
we'll go back and look at just a couple other
moments. Just a really tough night for Mark Levin.
Speaker 3: They're trying all these process crimes
and all these crimes to grow out of the criminal
investigation against Trump. What did he do with
the documents? Did he show up? For the enemy?
No. That's why we have an espionage act. Not
the trick of a president. What did he do? Did
he burn them all? No. The government has all
the documents back, so there is no violation
of the Presidential Records Act at this point.
But they throw the book at him. They go after his
attorneys. They make them testify, their attorneys
under the crime fraud exception to attorney client
privilege. That means he didn't have due process
for being subjected to interrogations.
And they had hundreds of in person.
Speaker 1: All right. I think you get
it. And then putting a final point on
it. Mark Levin talking about Trump's age.
Speaker 3: President Trump is 76 years old.
If the Department of Justice gets his way,
he will die in federal prison.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, I don't believe
that that's going to happen. I don't believe Trump
is going to do a single day of prison time. I've
said it before. I continue to believe that if I'm
wrong, I will eat my microphone. But I don't think
Trump's going to be doing any prison time at all.
An incredible 24 hours in America. We are going to
be covering Trump's arraignment as it as it will
will be on Tuesday at 3 p.m. live on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook. It is happening, ladies
and gentlemen. A now twice indicted and soon
to be twice arrested. Donald Trump will find
himself in federal custody before he knows it
Tuesday in a federal courthouse. I hope you
will join us for it. This is accountability,
at least the possibility of accountability
for many alleged misdeeds. And that is a
good thing. We're going to take a break.
What a program we have for you today.